riesige mengen plastik schwimmen in den
weltmeeren die ozeane verkommen zur
müllhalde hier eine krabbe gefangenen
plastik netz nicht nur die
meeresbewohner leiden nicht mehr ins
meer
denn dort bleibt das plastik sonst und
verteilt sich überall
was meinst du warst du mal ein plastik
freies mehr erleben
die lage ist ernst aber es gibt menschen
die sich darum kümmern finden sie
lösungen für saubere meere
[Musik]
kannst du auf dem verein los
früher war er geschäftsführer einer
großen erfolgreichen die firma günther
boni sein hobby siegel achten
dann hat er sein leben umgekrempelt
alles begann vor zehn jahren bei einem
segeltörn vor kanada
diese laufen vom frachter eingefahren er
hat einfach seinen küchen abfälle
plastiktüten und sagt dazu alles gemacht
hat oder immer noch macht über bord
geworfen dann hab ich mir die frage
gestellt wie wir schiffe gibt es auf der
welt sind 40.000 des skripts 1000
riesenschiffe um millionen von kleinen
schiffen und jeder schmeißt sein müller
bord was machen wir dann eigentlich mit
dem ganzen will günter bonin wird aktiv
er will nur noch eins die meere retten
ein resultat seiner mission die seekuh
so hat er liebevoll sein schiff genannt
sie soll auf den meeren aufräumen
die seco ist ein prototyp mit ihr wird
getestet und auch geforscht das labor an
bord betreut der mikrobiologe dr rüdiger
stöhr die idee von günter bonin die
sikom soll einmal in serie gehen und vor
allem in asien plastik aus dem wasser
holen denn dort leben millionen menschen
an flüssen ohne eine geordnete
müllentsorgung
wir zeigen jetzt mit den kanistern wie
ist denn aussehen könnte wenn wir jetzt
auch noch mehr sind hat das fangen wir
dann ein wenn du in große mengen an dem
wir so hoch ziehen die letzt
konstruktion ist relativ einfach
man kann sie auch aus lernt nach oben
wegziehen im kran die siko ist nur teil
einer viel größeren vision eine maritime
müllabfuhr flotte soll auf den meeren
und flüssen der ganzen welt unterwegs
sein bis zu 250 kilo müll kann eine
seiten pro fang in ihren netzen
aufnehmen
aber das reicht den termin noch nicht er
denkt groß und hat ein globales müll
sammeln und recycling konzept entwickelt
die maritime müllabfuhr
sie besteht aus drei bootstypen der
seekuh dem müllsammeln schiff bis mehr
und große flüsse den kleineren see
hamster einen müllsammler auf kleinen
flüssen und den großen see elefanten
einem container recycling chef fürs mehr
ich habe drei kanister hier die netze
der siko sind nicht gefährlich für
meerestiere
das ist ihm wichtig die sehen uns ja
wissen ja nicht was initiative sind
jetzt groß die cholera zeit raus also
wir haben noch nie einen lebendigen
plastik aus dem wasser ist genauso ein
wertstoff wieland müll und damit der
nächste milliardenmarkt
davon ist günter bonin überzeugt noch
finanziert er sein verein durch
stiftungen und sponsoren bis zum
komplett globalen konzept mit mit seiner
flotte könnte günter bonin den müll von
der oberfläche der weltmeere sammeln was
er und die meere noch brauchen sind
investoren aus der wirtschaft aber was
ist mit dem müll dinge nicht sehen weil
er schon längst am meeresgrund liegt
[Musik]
damit wir uns nicht missverstehen von
der laterne bis da hinten ist es die
chance sagt total verdreckt nicht nur
hier der ganze hafengrund ich möchte
betonen dass diese situation nicht nur
schulter fischer
dieser müll den wir im hafen er taucht
haben das ist hauptsächlich alltagsmüll
aus dem haushalt in nur zwei stunden hat
jörg zars mit seinem tauchkollegen
diesen ganzen müll aus dem hafen geholt
doch das ist nur ein teil des
unterwasser mülls ein anderer ist
erheblich schwerer zu bergen
deshalb hat der athena heute eine
weitere nicht ungefährliche mission als
begeisterter taucher setzt er alles
daran dass mehr sauberer zu machen
vor einem jahr hatte 40 jährige einen
verein gegründet seither ist er fast
jedes wochenende ehrenamtlich mit
anderen tauchern im mittelmeer unterwegs
wir haben gerade noch von zwei netzen
erfahren das müssen wir jetzt
koordinieren
bei so vielen leuten george soros und
die anderen taucher wollen verloren
gegangene oder weggeworfene fischernetze
aus dem meer holen
diese sogenannten geisternetz fischen
jahre lang unter wasser weiter unzählige
tiere sterben in ihm
wir befolgen den plan die gestern
gesprochen
[Musik]
jährlich enden rund 1250 km fischernetze
allein in den europäischen meeren
weltweit sind etwa zehn prozent des
meeres mülls fischernetze
beim fang verloren oder einfach
weggeschmissen
also es gibt lecks am grund dass sich
verfangen hat ist es groß
noch ist unklar wo sich das netz genau
befindet aber die taucher müssen jetzt
handeln
der segen zu die rettungsaktion ist in
gefahr
das große netz wurde von der strömung
weggerissen und es wird jetzt nicht
einfach
die taucher riskieren es und hoffen dass
sie schnell genug sind dann finden
george sanders und die taucher einen
ersten fast unscheinbaren hinweis das
netz hat sich in den felsen am grund
verfangen die bergung ist immer auch ein
risiko wissen die tauchen
es ist heikel weil die netze den taucher
unter wasser halten können
[Musik]
verfangen haben sich in den meilern
seien vor allem tiere die werden jetzt
erstmal befreit
[Musik]
dann muss das etwa 400 kilo schwere netz
nach oben
[Musik]
wir fahren die herren schauen ob die
taucher alle da sind ganz hin der das
netz an bord
wir haben ein erstes netz hier und das
andere da drüben in ihrem ersten
vereinsjahr haben die taucher in 25
einsätzen bereits 3,5 tonnen
fischernetze aus dem meer geborgen
allein in europa kümmern sich mehr als
zehn organisationen um das problem jetzt
müssen wir checken ob tiere im netz auch
wenn wir das schon unter wasser gemacht
haben das ist eine lebende krippe
gefangen im netz muss sie schnell das
geht zurück ins meer
viel spaß
sinnloses sterben verhindern george
soros und seine tauchen und es gibt noch
einen wichtigen grund der netze aus dem
meer zu holen
das ist noch ein recht neues netz es gab
kürzlich eine studie dass acht menschen
in acht verschiedenen ländern alle micro
plastik im magen hat
genau deshalb müssen wir alles plastik
aus dem meer holen
es wird
[Musik]
tiere retten und mikro plastik
verhindern jedes geborgene geisternetz
ist da ein erfolg
das nächste große problem wartet an land
wohin mit dem maritimen es fehlt an
recycling anlagen für meeres- abfälle um
zu zeigen wie nötig diese aber sind
stellen die taucher ihren geretteten
müll vom wochenende öffentlich aus
[Musik]
die leute haben schon fast die hälfte
von unserem taucher müll mitgenommen
aber sie scheinen ihn offenbar
gebrauchen zu können
das ist ja auch so eine art upcycling
und damit sind wir irgendwie auch
glücklich
[Musik]
nach jedem tauchgang wird der müll
aufgelistet und dabei noch der letzten
blinde passagier gerettet
george soros will beweisen dass meeres
movies eickel war ist und sich deshalb
maritime müll sammelstellen lohnen
besonders in asien sind müll und
plastikabfälle ein riesenproblem wenn
millionen menschen leben an flüssen ohne
geregelten müll entsorgung recycling
gibt es hier kaum
[Musik]
über die flüsse gelang gewaltige massen
von plastik bis ins meer
das könnte ein ende haben der müll soll
aus den flüssen und meeren gesammelt und
dann recycelt werden
mit dieser idee will günter bonin hier
in kambodscha die plastik flut stoppen
sein kleinster bootstyp ist hier seit
einem jahr im einsatz sie hans da heißt
der winzling der maritim müllabfuhr
sieht klein aus wie ein unscheinbares
schlauchboot aber der hamster kann
großes bewerten die rampe ins wasser
dann fahren wir da rein lassen sie
wieder runter und der müll kommt wenn 40
ist von alleine hoch
der vorteil des hamsters obwohl er so
klein ist kann er durch seine rampe viel
müll sammeln
er ist wendig leicht zu bedienen eignet
sich für enge gewässer und nach bedarf
ausgestattet werden kann er auch
jeder ort hat man probleme könnten noch
kleiner machen wir können noch größer
machen also die idee ist eigentlich an
anfragen aus großen städten aus asien
wollen teilweise bis zu 80 stück davon
haben in batam bahn gibt es zurzeit
einen see hamster die crew an bord sind
studierte umweltexperten und bei günter
bonin angestellt das element wasser ist
ihnen noch recht fremd
der fahrer aber noch zweiter ausbilden
dass mehrere leute mit dem maschine
auffahren können
das ist eigentlich relativ einfach aber
an und ablegen strömungen wassertiefe
das haben wir ja vorher noch nicht
gemacht sie kennt sich mit müll aus aber
das ist noch nicht mit der seefahrt man
muss man geduld haben
wobei ich sagen muss ich zu den
ungeduldigen leuten aber ruhig noch ein
bisschen vorfahren in bad bank ist viel
passiert seit günter bonin erfindung
hier müll hamstert auf dem fluss und an
den ufern sammeln freiwillige dreimal
die woche unrat auf
[Musik]
so wie hier könnte es an vielen
flussufern in asien aussehen wenn sie
einen see hamster hätten
der fluss bestimmt das leben der
menschen in batam bank
sie profitieren von den neuen besseren
wasserqualität und nicht nur sie denn
der fluss mündet in den mekong und der
mekong fließt ins meer schleppen wo es
sinn macht die am meer sind wir wollen
wir entwickeln die lokale probleme lösen
und somit die auch anpassen
in so einer kurzen zeit wo es relativ
schon gereinigt aussieht dass wir noch
so viel finden auch unter wasser oder
was so ein bisschen hoch guckt
wasseroberfläche die
umweltwissenschaftlerin arbeitet an
einer studie
die ist auch wichtig für den deutschen
unternehmer sören der geschäftsführer
eines folienherstellers ist einer der
förderer des see hamster projektes in
deutschland arbeitet der betrieb bereits
mit recyceltem plastik
nun will sie herausfinden ob der plastik
0 in kambodscha auch zum recycling
geeignet ist ein betrag zu überweisen
damit dass hier einmal sauber gemacht
wird und in zwei jahren sieht genauso
aus wie vorher das ist nicht der sinn
und zweck der sache sondern unsere idee
ist es dass aus den abfällen wertstoffe
werden damit am ende des tages diese
maritime müller fuhr sich auch rechnet
weil sie durch die abfälle die die
kosten wieder einspielen kann - günter
bonin den deutschen recyclinganlagen
dass die qualität und die menge des
gesammelten und getrennten plastiks
grund ist die idee von günter bonin
meeres und plus x als wirtschaftsfaktor
zu nutzen ist ein ansatz aber bis das
den meeren hilft wird es noch dauern
die kann heute schon jeder die meere
plastik schützen
[Musik]
in großbritannien surfer hauptstadt
tokio sind an diesem wochenende wieder
einmal fast perfekte wellen
doch nicht alle sind deshalb am strand
ein beachclub findet statt colette
beckham hat ihn organisiert und nicht
nur diesen es ist die dreißigste saubere
aktion an einem kiesstrand in dieser
saison
wir leben an der küste und seen as
plastik problem immer wieder wenn du am
strand läuft dann siehst du wie das
plastik mit jeder flut kommt das ist so
die deshalb mobilisiert colette beckham
seit monaten die einwohner von nykky ihr
ziel ein leben ohne plastik über 1000
freiwillige hat sie schon für strand
säuberungsaktionen zusammengetrommelt
das sieht noch nicht viel aus aber in
dieser schnur können sich viele tiere
verfangen
wir haben hier plastik flaschen dosen
und glasflaschen
wir sind urlauber und es ist schön etwas
zurückzugeben
dieser strand ist es vor kurzem
bereinigt worden
aber wie man sieht dass gerade ebbe und
wenn das wasser wieder kommt wird es
eine frische ladung plastik mitbringen
und an den strand
wir müssen immer wieder und das problem
im auge behalten
beckham hat in den letzten monaten ihre
gesamte freizeit investiert damit micky
eine plastik freie stadt wird aber es
braucht mehr als das plastik nur ein
zusammen
davon sind viele menschen in
großbritannien überzeugt 478 orte haben
bereits den plastik viel status eine
landesweite bürgerbewegung macht sich
auf con ect beckham hat die bewegung in
ihre stadt geholt dazu mussten sie unter
anderem anti plastik verließ wie die
beach clubs organisieren
eine lenkungsgruppe einrichten lokale
unternehmen und organisationen
überzeugen plastik zu reduzieren
ihr wechsel teuer sortiment gerade ja
das sind ein paar unserer neuen produkte
plastik frei nächste woche eröffnet
durch diese kampagne der erste serien
waste laden er versucht müll komplett zu
vermeiden was werdet ihr noch verkaufen
wir werden in großen behältern reis
nudeln kräuter haferflocken tee und
kaffee verkaufen
den kaffee kaufen wir auch lokale
also alles lebensmitteln die man jeden
tag braucht ihr connect barcamp ist
gartenbau architektin und mutter seit
neun monaten engagiert sie sich
ehrenamtlich damit die stadt als plastik
frei zertifiziert wird an einer auflage
zweifelte sie zunächst sehr auch der
stadtrat muss dauerhaft nicht machen
verschiedene serien jahre
[Musik]
der skatepark hat zwar mülleimer aber
bisher keine recycling behälter
vielleicht könnten wir da zusammen etwas
tun
wir haben jemanden der sie anfertigen
und aufstellen kann
wir warten noch auf die bestätigung von
dort das ist klasse als wir anfingen war
ich skeptisch ob es sinn macht den
stadtrat einzubinden
die schien mir so steif aber es hat mir
wirklich die augen geöffnet was erreicht
werden kann wenn die stadt leitung mit
und hilft die botschaft an die einwohner
weiter zu schließen
der skatepark ist ein fantastisches
beispiel weil sie die jungen leute
erreichen und plastik zu vermeiden
es ist gar nicht so schwer plastik frei
zu werden
es gibt herausforderungen auch auf der
persönlichen ebene aber als stadt werden
wir viel fortschrittlicher und seen
jünger aus als früher
großbritannien macht vor die plastik
vermeidung wirksam umgesetzt werden kann
nach vielen anläufen hat auch die
europäische kommission eine plastik
strategie zum schutz der meere vorgelegt
ab 2021 sollen einige produkte aus
einbeck plastik verboten oder reduziert
werden
ab 2030 sollen alle
kunststoffverpackungen auf dem eu-markt
recyclingfähig seien aber ein anfang
kann jeder machen angenommen jeder
deutsche würde in diesem jahr an einen
strand nur ein kilo müll einsammeln
dann würden hochgerechnet rund 80.000
tonnen weniger plastik im meer landen in
niki haben die einwohner den mehr
bereits schon mehrere hundert tonnen
erspart ich bin stolz auf mich weil ich
nicht bewegt habe
aber ich denke er mit stolz bin ich auf
jeden weg geholfen
das war eine echte gemeinschaftsleistung
jetzt geht es darum wie wir das nutzen
uns zu motivieren weiterzumachen
diese dynamik weiter zu entwickeln und
veränderungen in unserer gemeinschaft
zuvor
ich denke das ist das wichtigste
du wirst das vielleicht noch erleben auf
den tag ich mich auch
[Musik]
ein plastik freies mehr ist auch der
traum von günter bonin hier in
kambodscha soll das durch die
wiederverwertung des mülls gelingen
gemeinsam mit dem geschäftsführer des
deutschen folienherstellers besucht er
eine mülldeponie sören geprüft ob hier
eine recyclinganlage sinn macht dafür
muss der müll gut vorsortiert sein ist
ja schon mal gut dass das alles
transparente folie ist als ich die idee
dazu hatte aus - kunststoffen
abfallsäcken zu machen da haben wir alle
mit denen ich darüber gesprochen habe
gesagt das wird nicht funktionieren das
kann nicht funktionieren
du kommst du bist nicht an die sache ran
kommen du wirst es sich leisten können
die qualität der getrennten folie ist
auf den ersten eindruck vielversprechend
vielleicht lohnt es sich für das
unternehmen von sören leder in einer
recyclinganlage vor ort zu investieren
günter bonin hofft dass das würde den
menschen hier helfen
sie sind im deutschen mittlerweile ans
herz gewachsen hier trifft man die
ärmsten menschen überhaupt und ihre ihre
kinder und deswegen haben uns auch mit
komplett und dem zusammengetan mit der
ngo aus deutschland weil die seit zehn
jahren und länger hier ein soziales
abfall center betreiben wo die kinder
der müllsammler den ganzen tag versorgt
werden essen kriegen die kinder sind
nicht unglücklich wenn man sie sieht sie
freuen sich und spielen aber sie sollten
eigentlich besser chance haben deshalb
arbeitet günter bonin mit der deutschen
nonprofit organisation komplett zusammen
der deutsche ist überzeugt man muss auf
dem land und bei den menschen anfangen
um die mehrere langfristig zu schützen
die kinder sollen in zukunft bessere
lebensbedingungen haben
und ihre eltern hoffentlich bald arbeit
wenn hier recycling eingeführt wird
ob es sich für das unternehmen rechnet
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir da ein
tragfähiges projekt aufmachen können
diesmal ein besuch in meinen augen doch
deutlich gestiegen weil ich einfach hier
mehr vor ort ein bild machen konnte das
würde bedeuten möglichst viele see
hamster sammeln müll
der wird von den müllsammlern sortiert
und bestenfalls in einer recyclinganlage
direkt nebenan verwertet die visionäre
haben hier viel erreicht aber in asien
ist noch einiges zu tun vor allem im
bereich naturschutz auch da denkt günter
bonin nachhaltig in deutschland hat sam
faller umwelt ingenieurwesen studiert
nun leitet er boni ins
aufklärungskampagne in kambodscha das
thema mülltrennung ist neu in kambodscha
und sam fall muss ganz von vorne
anfangen
das plastikmüll giftig ist den boden und
das wasser verschmutzt und die menschen
krank macht
den einmal ist nicht genug ist normal 23
mal kommen damit sie wieder weiß dann
ist problemlos
und das bewusstsein in der bevölkerung
ändert sich
wenn wir etwas essen dann dürfen wir den
müll nicht einfach auf die straße oder
in den fluss werfen
das schadet der umwelt
[Musik]
wir brauchen endlich ein vernünftiges
will entsorgungssystem
der see hamster macht den anfang und
günter bonin ist sich sicher mit einem
vernünftigen recycling konzept wird bald
auch weniger müll in die flüsse gelangen
und zwar auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
wie dringlich ein weltweites handeln ist
untersucht bonin gemeinsam mit dem
mikrobiologen rüdiger stöhr in
deutschland denn plastikmüll im meer hat
bereits messbare folgen
wenn
es geht hauptsächlich um den nachweis
von mikro plastik im wasser jetzt mit
der seekuh hier in kiel haben auch die
möglichkeit selber hier in der ostsee
proben zu nehmen sie jetzt hier schon
ein partikel der fällt durch seine
färbung auf und durch seine größe den
werden wir auf jeden fall gleich und
analysieren
das abfischen von so kleinen teilchen
aus dem meer ist unmöglich
wir machen das seit 2013 und in den
ersten drei jahren habe ich festgestellt
dass in 73 prozent aller untersuchten
filter mindestens ein plastikteil war
und den nachfolgenden zwei jahren schon
bei 89 prozent das ist sehr erschreckend
auch dieses mal landet der
wissenschaftler einen treffer doch wie
entsteht micro plastik überhaupt bin
plastikmüll ins meer gelangt er setzt er
sich im laufe der zeit in immer kleinere
fragmente fische und vögel neben die
teilchen auf dadurch gelangen sie in die
nahrungskette
[Musik]
plastik ist überall im essen wenn wir so
weitermachen ist absehbar dass dass wir
unsere besser unsere luft und alles noch
mehr verschmutzen und dann ist nur die
frage wer da an krank wird oder wer
daran stirbt oder ob wir da überhaupt
überleben deshalb will günter bonin
dafür sorgen dass plastikmüll als einer
der verursacher für micro plastik aus
dem meer geholt wird und bestenfalls gar
nicht mehr rein gelangt direkt in der
kieler förde hat er seine büros elf
angestellte arbeiten für ihn gerade wird
sein bisher größter prototyp fertig
jetzt endlich haben wir jetzt genau die
prozess schritte auf diesem schiff ja
mal darstellen lassen und das ist das 3d
modell dazu nach sie hamster sie jetzt
der see elefanten containerschiff mit
recycling anlage das elephant soll jetzt
das aufgesammelte plastik was wir zum
beispiel mit der sie aufsammeln dann in
produkte umwandeln
zum beispiel in plastikfolie die dann
direkt auf dem meer entsteht ein teil
des plastiks soll sogar einmal zu öl
verwandelt werden können
350.000 euro entwicklungskosten stecken
in dem schiff
sie haben es doch mal kleine haben
gelächelt was willst du denn im kleinen
ding da dann keine sekunde haben sie
gemerkt hatte dass doch ein fein
dahinter der der also schon wirklich
ernst macht jetzt kommen wir mit dem
seeland
ich lasse mir nicht von kleinigkeit
ablenken weil ich habe der große bild
ich will den see elefanten haben ich
will auf dem meer umfahren und ich will
dass es ein bisschen besser wird
die idee von günter bonin könnte dabei
helfen dass die weltmeere sauberer
werden
das funktioniert aber nur wenn die
politik wirksame maßnahmen gegen die
plastik blut ergreift und wer alle
weniger plastik verbrauchen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]